اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني انا
بلاده لا تريد صراعا مع بيجين ولا تسعى
لحرب بارده جديده معها لكنها ستدافع دون
اعتذار عن قيمها ومصالحها وعلى هامش مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن حذر بلينكن رئيس لجنه شؤون
رئيس لجه الشؤون الخارجيه لللجه المركزيه
للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
حذره متداعياته وعواقب تقديم الصين دعما
ماديا لروسيا او مساعدتها في التهرب من
العقوبات وجدد بلانكا التاكيد انه لم يطرا
اي تغيير على سياسه واشنطن بشان مبدا
الصين الواحده وشدد على اهميه الحفاظ على
السلام والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
كما شدد بريكن الى نظيره الصينيه على عدمه
تكرار ما وصفه بانتهاك برنامج مناطيد
التجسس الصيني للمجال الجوي الامريكي
والقانون الدولي